eine ukrainische spezialeinheit in einem
wald in der donbass region die männer
gehen leise und gut getarnt durch das
grün und beginnen den wald zu verdienen
panzer abwehr minen werden verlegt um
die vorrückenden russischen truppen zu
stoppen mit kleinen spaten heben die
ukraine löcher aus verbuddeln auf dem
waldweg zahlreiche tm 62 minen aus
sowjetischer zeit auch deutsche panzer
abwärme vom typ dm 22 werden platziert
um die flanke vom möglichen russischen
angriffen zu schützen
die männer ziehen weiter verliehen das
gelände großflächig verbreitet werden
die bilder über die nachrichtenagentur
ap
denn die russen bombardieren tag für tag
die östliche donbass region das
industrielle kern land der ukraine wird
langsam aber stetig von den russen
erobert eine artillerie und panzer
schlacht bei der es ukraine weiter an
schweren waffen fehlt die aus großer und
damit sicherer entfernung russische
ziele ins visier nehmen können
haubitzen wie die m 777 haben eine
höhere reichweite wie die mehrfach
raketenwerfer aus sowjetzeiten zb können
damit feuern ohne selbst von den russen
unter beschuss genommen zu werden
um das vorrücken von putins truppen
jetzt zumindest hier zu stoppen familien
die ukraine ihre wälder